chatter is not without fault women's
rights and gay rights are restricted by
Western standards migrant workers have
indispitably been treated badly
but those statements apply to many of
the countries around the world including
many competing in this tournament and by
many nations who've hosted major
sporting events without anything like
the furore that's kicked off about Qatar
we seem to have forgotten in England
that in 1966 when we hosted and won the
World Cup it was illegal to be gay in
our country
moral Halos appear to have slipped over
some people's eyes and skewed some
rather Salient facts for example there's
12 of the population here are native
qataris something William is supposedly
sophisticated West would never tolerate
the migrants who come here in vast
numbers are sometimes mistreated but the
reason they're here in the first place
is because the wages they earn are
life-changing and the global scrutiny of
the World Cup has at least led to
reforms in labor laws here that will be
an important Legacy and one massively
lacking after two Olympic Games in China
and a World Cup in Russia
Qatar is also a significant investor in
many aspects of UK life for example it
gives us 25 of our gas
which is Food For Thought isn't it is
our national grid considers winter
blackouts with all the virtue signalers
back home prefer we tell Qatar to stop
sending its gas
this tournaments brought the football
mad Middle East together as well two
years ago Qatar was under a blockade led
by Saudi Arabia Bahrain and the UAE now
fans from most countries are pouring in
to enjoy the football saudi's Crown
Prince was at the opening ceremony the
Emir of Qatar even waved a Saudi flag
during their stunning win over Messi's
Argentina
there's no denying the Middle East has a
long way to go on human rights and many
social issues but so frankly to a lot of
European countries there's also no
denying that this region the Middle East
has long deserved its World Cup
and there's no denying and I can tell
you this is what most people here are
thinking that right now qatar's putting
on a pretty good show
and frankly when it comes to morality
are we in England really in any position
to lecture the Middle East about laws or
values given the way we illegally
invaded Iraq 20 years ago sparked in two
decades of Isis Terror and at last
year's Euros final showed the world that
we're a bunch of coke snorting booze
sodden brawling firework exploding from
backside imbeciles
me thinks not
well Hassan al-tawadi is the Secretary
General of the Supreme committee for
delivery Legacy which is a fancy title
for he pretty well runs a World Cup here
in Qatar he's the man of the Helm of the
most controversial tournament in World
Cup history for reasons that frankly
baffleman and he spoke to me a little
earlier today I began by asking how he
felt about Qatar hosting the tournament
and how he thought he was going
we're immensely proud of of the World
Cup as you know and everything has been
unfolded since uh since the 20th of
November it's it's a moment of great
pride I mean you know just just if you
look at what's happening on the streets
people from all over the world coming in
celebrating uh the story is unfolding in
the pitch the stadiums from a
footballing perspective phenomenal great
um well Saudi Arabia beating Argentina
for the region absolutely well
absolutely I mean you know and then and
then Morocco just recently beating
Belgium uh yesterday I mean that in
itself is a phenomenal story as well
this is the first World Cup in the Arab
world this is the first World Cup in the
Middle East in the Islamic world you see
it not only in you know not only in
terms of the teams participating but you
see it in the stadiums I mean I I was
seeing some of the punditry where you
had the fans it was predominantly red
Moroccan supporters and it's not just
Maracas flying over here it's supporters
of the Moroccan national team from the
Arab uh population Living in Qatar
visiting qatars Saudi supporters were
supporting Morocco Moroccan supporters
who are supporting Saudi and Tunisia and
so on uh you know for our part of the
world for our region this is this is a
you know I have to say you know as
qataris as Arabs we're extremely proud
of this moment how have you reacted as a
senior Qatari one of the real key people
in this world come
particularly from the criticism from the
UK for example
I think you know from day one what we
try to do is distinguish between two
forms of criticism
there's constructive criticism
that we've taken on board we've engaged
with uh we've talked to our critics who
had a genuine interest in terms of you
know progress or working with us towards
utilizing this this tournament as a
transformational vehicle for Qatar and
for the region and as I said we've
engaged with them we've discussed things
with them and they've become Partners in
the end and then there's of course
criticism that I think is based on uh
misinformation
uh misrepresented facts misstated facts
and even even towards you know these and
whether it's whether it's media Outlets
or individuals we've also reached out
and tried to engage and tried to set the
facts straight
um and some unfortunately have not been
as as as receptive of our efforts but
nevertheless we've always said one thing
the most important element is
um our response is always going to be by
actions as opposed to words
the BBC coverage is a friend of mine
full disclosure big fan of his work over
the years both on the pitch or not but
he did a sort of monologue at the start
of the BBC's coverage pointing out all
the bad things about Qatar I know what I
felt was he didn't do that at the Russia
World Cup
um they didn't run your opening ceremony
this time the BBC on the main Channel
they did in Russia they ran it for
example with the China Olympics of
Beijing Winter Olympics yes it seems to
me to be a bit of a double standard
though well it's it's it's it's it's
disappointing you know for an
institution such as a BBC you know a
particular BBC Sports in an institution
that has always known or at least you
know as I grew up was always known to be
you know objective and stating the facts
and allowing for you know different
points of view to be addressed and for
the audience to make their own decision
uh for the actions that you've mentioned
for example you know and again in
particular with Gary the frustration is
that we've reached out to we've reached
out to him many times the latest if I'm
not mistaken was in February about three
or four times for a sit-down and at the
very least again with the idea we'll
present our case whatever judgment you
want to pass later on that's that's
that's up to you but at least for us to
present the counter argument show you
know show what what we've done how we've
utilized this tournament and how really
this tournament is a historical event
what you've seen stadiums what you see
outside the engagement the cultural
engagement the funds the way people are
dressing yeah I mean I mean you know
just a little side Side Story you know
over the years as I did a lot of
interviews especially from back home I'm
always dressed like this and a lot of my
friends whether they're journalists and
even some experts always try to try to
convince me to dress in a western way
even from the Qatar dressed in a western
way why should we fall on you anything
frankly whether it's our our values that
we have in the UK the way we dress the
way we talk the way we drink I'm not
sure that we're in any position to take
the high moral ground as a country which
for example invaded Iraq illegally in
2003 an invasion I opposed as a
newspaper Predator does that give us
bragging rights on morality with the
Middle East I'm not sure that it does I
do want to turn to some things where I
think I I would say other criticism
notably migrant workers The Guardian
newspaper said that six and a half
thousand migrant workers have died as a
result of the World Cup Construction
I've looked into this I saw many other
fact checkers
figures deeply misleading us because
it's actually the number of migrants
who've died in total in the last 12
years since the bid was confirmed for
Qatar of any cause do you know how many
migrant workers have died as a result of
any construction since the announcement
of the bid in terms of you know what we
did from day one at least within the
organization that I'm responsible for as
we were committed towards being
transparent
and you know capturing any incidents
whether it's in terms of you know misses
near misses accidents or unfortunately
deaths and we decided to capture and we
made a decision in terms of obviously
work-related deaths as defined under the
you know industry standard but also
capturing what we consider to be
non-work related deaths and this is only
purely in relation to the stadiums right
and the projects that we're responsible
for and what are those totals and that's
three work-related deaths and 37
non-work related deaths these are the
specific to World Cup construction
specific to World Cup do you know how
many people have died in Qatar since you
won the bid in the last 12 years from
any construction related to anything to
do the World Cup in other words new
hotels new Bridges whatever whatever in
other words what is the honest realistic
total do you think of Migrant workers
who've died from as a result of what
they're doing for the World Cup in
totality
the estimate is around 400. before
between 400 and 500 I don't know I don't
have the exact number that's that's
something that's been discussed I mean
there will be people and Sony say that's
a lot of people
let me say 400 is a price too big to pay
what do you say to that
what I will say is
one death is a death too many plain and
simple
um and I think every year uh the health
and safety standards on the sites are
improving at least on our sites the
World Cup sites the ones that we're
responsible for most definitely to the
extent that you've got trade unions
representatives of the German Trade
union representatives of the Swiss
Traders and you accept they have I just
just at this point have commended the
work that's been done on on the side on
the World Cup side right and
improvements right but do you accept
them because of the improvements that
have been made that at the start they
weren't good enough the standards I
think overall the need for labor reform
in itself dictates that yes improvements
had to happen and just so we're clear
this was something that was recognized
before we bid the improvements that have
happened isn't because of the World Cup
these are improvements that we knew we
had to do
because of our own values improvements
that have to happen whether it's in
terms of health and safety standards
whether it's in terms of improving
accommodations as standards whether it's
in terms of dismantling the cafala
system now what the World Cup did the
World Cup served as a vehicle as an
accelerant as a catalyst it you know
because of the spotlight which we
recognized early on was going to be shed
it allowed you know it caused a lot of
these initiatives not only in terms of
improvement in the legislation but in
the enforcement of it as well and that's
where today you know where we led to you
know
we got to a position where
our most Ardent of critics consider us
today to be a benchmark
in the region let me ask you about LGBT
rights because a lot of furore about
this and in particular the wearing of
the armbands so the England Captain
Harry Kane and several of the European
country captains were all going to wear
for one love armband did you personally
have any problem with them doing that if
it was done specifically to address
Qatar I had a problem with it right if
it was done some you know for something
that was going to be done and the
European nations were going to be you
know holding it you're just wearing it
continuously and constantly then of
course that's a decision that they you
know that that's up to them it was FIFA
right to say if they wear it they'd all
get bookings
again it's a decision that FIFA's made
between them and and the European
nations and I think you know became a
standoff and that was a discussion that
was that was between them for me what
I'm trying to you know what what for our
position and my personal position is
look you know uh we've always said
everybody's welcome and and you know
we've worked very hard to create an
environment
um and to ensure that people from all
parts of the world and all walks of life
come into come coming to Qatar engage
and interact with people from the Arab
world and the Middle East
um even though we might not necessarily
see eye to eye on certain things even
though we might not agree on certain
things
um but everybody's welcome and the point
is you know to to to come to terms with
the fact that we won't see eye to eye
but we can still have mutual respect for
each other and still find a way of
moving forward celebrating together and
I think is it safe for gay people to be
in Qatar yes
unequivocally appears yes and safe for
gay people to live in Qatar yes
I think it's safe for everybody to live
in Canada Pierce but you there would be
a problem with a gay couple for example
showed demonstrative displays of public
display of affection generally is not
part of our culture
public display of affection is not part
of our culture
um it's not you know regardless of who
you are regardless of your your sexual
identification or or and so on public
display of affection is not and again I
say that and I mean within reason
um you know holding hands in the streets
is fine uh the gay people
holding hands in the streets for
anybody's fine it is
um
but what I'm saying is you know there's
there's you know public intimacy you
know public intimacy is not part of our
culture we're a relatively conservative
culture in the West
the the individual's personal rights
always Trump
um let's say the community rights that's
that's what's most sacred now there are
other societies our society being one of
them you know the Arab world in the
Middle East where it's the communal
values it's the values of the community
in society which is also again
fundamentally related to religion as
well that is that is a that is a you
know of a higher value of higher
importance and again the question then
becomes what is more important you know
if you're coming from a western
value-based system you look at
individual rights regardless of any
other uh aspect that should always be
sacred and from our part of the world
it's the religious values that are there
what I'm trying to say is at points in
time these discussions you know to try
to find a winner out of them or try to
find you know for somebody to kind of
defeat somebody else in terms of the
discussions
um the reality is that there will be no
winner but what we have to do is find
you know or at least that's what we try
to do is find common ground find
something at least that unites us and
come to terms with the fact that we
might not see eye to eye on certain
things but we have to find a way of
coexisting and moving forward and what
this world cup is showcased again taking
it back to what you see on the streets
taking back to it to where you see the
engagement taking it back to where
you're seeing you know the Brazilian and
the uh Saudi singing where's Messi after
the loss of after the defeat of
Argentina seeing the argentinians coming
and you know finding the Saudis and
saying where's that solemn when they
lost against Poland looking at people
dressing like you know I've seen
somebody dressing you know wearing the
film but in the Portuguese flag I've
seen the Croatian flag
um I saw a tweet yesterday that that for
me was just absolutely funny a guy
saying you know never in my life that
was I expecting to see a Spaniard
rushing because he's late to watch uh
the Spanish match holding on to his
headgear
um
what's happening outside
the celebration of cultures I want to
end on a positive it's been a positive
interview
um who's going to win the World Cup
you know give me a name I need a name
it's okay
I'll leave it back in three weeks I'll
say France France I think France
uh led by Fabian and the French team yes
I think
actually I think England have a good
chance England have got a great job
Harry Kane remains fit and they play
phone
but I also think Portugal at a chance
with my friend Christiana of course
because I think he's got a vision of
himself lifting that cup and they have a
very good side well you know just to be
fair as well for me I want England to
win so we're clear I don't want anyone
it'd be great to have you know English
football history connected to Qatar
forever yeah awesome thank you very much
thank you very much good to talk to you
thank you